[Music]
he's a Content ke do you know the true
Jordan you're going to decide that are
you what the is wrong with it you
know how they play I want to be
[Applause]
out welcome back to the true Jordie
podcast today's guest is one of my
favorite new content creators uh
discovered Billy Carson um recent after
going down a rabbit hole um Billy thanks
for coming
on thank you man I'm glad to be here and
thanks for inviting me I really
appreciate it it's very rare that I get
hooked on someone's content these days
I'm I feel like I'm all contented out
but um we recently had David icon and it
is funny how certain people's sort of
opinions overlap and David was talking
about how the angels that we've been
told about from being kids in in school
were were actually aliens and um and
getting into your content and seeing how
far down the rabit hole you've gone and
how intelligent and well researched you
are it really brought it to life and um
I'm just looking forward to my audience
reacting to what you've got to say mate
um so so kind of if you could start off
by giving us a little bit about you and
and the research you've been doing and
and where you're at right now yeah
definitely well um obviously my name is
Billy Carson I'm the founder of four
bited knowledge with the number four
it's not a gang sign by the way and uh
got you gotta say that these days
everybody I got so many messages about
the is that are you a Mason no it's
forbidden knowledge but anyway I was
born in New York uh
1971 uh we came down to Miami Florida to
live I was outside in my backyard one
day just playing around flipping around
in the grass looking about at the sky
Watching airplanes go over from the
private airport and this object comes
across but it wasn't what I knew to be a
plane even at the age of seven I knew it
didn't have a fuselage a tail a pit
and wings those are kind of the main you
know things you need for an airplane and
this thing cleared the Horizon in my
backyard it went across in seconds not
minutes a normal plane would just kind
of go across looking from our
perspective on the ground kind of slow
and even I knew as a kid it went too
fast and I was like whoa what did I see
then it came back and then it just
stopped my only now I can estimate about
200 meters above my head completely
silent almost a complete egg shape but
slightly less than an egg oval glowing
metal and it went the way it came in I
mean just blink it's gone and I ran in
the house I told my mom you know she was
just telling me yeah she said Advanced
beings existed in the ancient past and
she started telling me about matchu
Pichu she said they used to live on tops
of mountains this is in the70s wow my
mom told me this and she didn't
discourage me about the information
whatsoever but nobody else really really
wanted to talk about it but the next day
I went to my school uh Rainbow Park
Elementary and I started researching
from the encyclopedia britanica that day
uh all the Aerospace information sweep
wi Delta wi uh you know I looked for
ballistics InterContinental ballistics I
mean I went to everything experimental
planes you know they were even talking
about back then in the 70s the potential
for the shuttle program back then so I
started digging into Aerospace I came
kind of a quasi Aerospace historian and
that rabbit hole of looking into all
these Declassified types of aircraft
just took me down a million rabbit holes
over the years which got me into
studying uh you know Advanced
Technologies uh of course black budgeted
Technologies which then took me into uh
ancient civilizations because in my
opinion some type of tech created those
ancient sites which led me down so many
more rabbit holes into ancient tablets
and scriptures papyruses cylinder
Scrolls I've now traveled the world over
30 times I've been to a lot of ancient
sites and places and met with indigenous
wisdom Keepers all around the world gone
through over a thousand books papyruses
script scriptures cylinder Scrolls and
ancient texts from everywhere you could
think of uh spent countless hours out in
the desert walk walkabouts in the in the
outback with aboriginals I've done it
all and so I've been able to come up
with a lot of my hypothesis and
conclusion based on a lot of firsthand
research and a lot of scholarly research
as well that have happened over many
decades I I kind of want to start us off
on what I've been reading and watching a
lot of what you've been saying on about
the aliens the anunaki and and and how
much evidence there is in ancient
history that really seems to have been
not really talked about to like I've
been in I've been in history class and
I've never heard never heard anything
about it and I'm listening to you being
like how old is this stuff so so maybe
we can go down that Avenue to start off
with and I think this interview can be a
very kind of basic compared to how far
you go because I do want to touch on a
lot of things uh that I've heard you
talk about in in a bit of detail and
then maybe part two can come and we can
really go into it but um in terms of the
information you've come AC across the
tablets and the Scrolls and scriptures
how old is that like do you know how old
it is yeah well the tablets and
scriptures and well the oldest text we
know of is around 40,000 years old Max
okay that's the oldest text we're
talking about The Emerald Tablets of do
it's between 36 to 40,000 years old and
that might even be a copy from a much
older tablet but we do have an account
of these beings that goes far beyond
that when you look at the enuma Elish
and the Seven Tablets of Creation we
discover that epic has been copied over
and over again and the oldest version is
approximately 6,500 years old and we
know that they're talking about
something that happened prior to that
writing approximately
450,000 years ago so we're talking about
deep deep deep Antiquity knowledge of
super ancient information super
Antiquity so far back we can't even
really grasp that human beings could be
Advanced and that there could be beings
visiting and so forth and so on all this
going on that far back and you mentioned
th and and I hear you referencing I
assume it's a him uh a lot can you tell
me a bit about him and and what sort of
things he wrote down yes he's one of
these ancient beings that uh I primarily
wrote my book about he wrote The Emerald
Tablets of do and those tablets are like
I said 36 to 40,000 years old uh what's
interesting about this being is he
didn't claim to be a God he never
masquerad as a god like the majority of
his relatives if you want to call them
that right his consorts or his peers
they were these were Advanced beings
that had faces like you and I their body
structure slightly different a little
bit larger a little bit different but we
they recognizable as a person that you
can talk to and they can speak back and
he became known as the first
Intelligencer he traveled around this
entire planet bringing knowledge wisdom
civilization all around the planet more
specifically in the land of chem or
Kemet where he developed Alchemy and
chemistry comes out of the land of chem
which is pre-dynastic Egypt and this guy
literally uh is responsible according to
him for the building of the Great
Pyramid he said build it I the Great
Pyramid so that it too might last uh you
know remain Through the Ages so this guy
is a real sophisticated architect he's
got the blueprints and he tells his team
to go around the planet and duplicate
what they rebuilt in Kemet after the
great flood but he said that they were
going to bring civilization back up to a
high level which means it had already
been at a high level prior to the flood
which the Samaran tabis the Kings list
documents this which is located in the
ash molan Museum in Oxford England so
this guy's a wisdom keeper super SM
super smart being who claims to have
even conquered death through knowing how
to create Avatar bodies and transfer his
Consciousness from body to body he said
so he can walk amongst men but unlike a
man wow okay so you're a smart dude bro
I'm going to try and keep it with you so
when you talk about um you know he
didn't claim to be a a God for example
um and it kind of I think you described
this in one of your interviews I watched
where you said like if you think about
it if we went back in time now from the
version of us that we are now even a
couple of thousand years ago and we have
phones and knowledge and a lot of the
things that they didn't have back then
they we could pose as Gods if we wanted
to so so when you say he chose not to he
wasn't really a quote unquote God he but
he wasn't of of the same Origins as
human he was something else yes he was
something else these people came from
other planets and record of this can be
discovered all over the world you have
the Doan tribe the original inhabitants
of the land of kmet before they got
overthrown and moved out to Mali Africa
but the Doan tribe they talk about the
Nomo coming from the star system Sirius
right Sirius B which is a a star that
ran out of fuel these beings created a
breakaway civilization here on Earth you
have the Zulu tribe same exact story
then you have have the indigenous people
of the Americas the red man right he's
talking about the same thing our Star
Brothers they seated us on this planet
they seated us they according to the
according to them the indigenous Native
Americans they were seated here by
pleadians then what's crazy is you I go
to Australia I'm out in the outback with
AB Originals they have the same exact
story we're the first people on this
planet they say in their verbal handed
down history for thousands of years is
that they were Seated on this planet by
pleadians and there's pleadian
hieroglyphs in the Outback at Kong
which nobody on the planet has been able
to decipher yet and they date back 5,000
years because of the patina inside of
the glyphs that's been dated back to
5,000 years verified so we know that
there's this story going on no matter
what culture you go to around the world
you can go to the eural of you know
Russia and Europe and you can go to
Bosnia and the Bosnian pyramid area the
stories just are the same exact stories
beings from somewhere else came came
here according to the ancient Egyptians
they say they the Nuru came here they
call him the Nuru and it's th they
depict him on the edu Temple th Isis
Horus Osiris and those beings they claim
came at the time of zepi that's the
beginning times and they said they they
turn mud into a kingdom and of course
the samarians have the same exact story
in the surian tablets in the udras Epic
in the inum Elish and so many more you
can read the mahabarata the bagita all
these texts are telling the same story
people from somewhere else and I do mean
people not little green men with little
antenna people that we can identify as a
person that we can speak to back and
forth and learn from uh they engaged Us
in uh in some way shape or form uh and
they came to this planet and created a
breakaway civilization and why my my my
my research tells me that there was a
war that happened in the pleades and I'm
covering this in my new TV series Anon
history which is coming out next year
and so this war created a situation
where a weapon was used called the
Brahma Honda weapon which had the power
to destroy any man on three worlds it
was blowing up planets it was blowing up
moons imagine if Mars blew up right now
on Earth we'd be really scared because
of debris that can come and create a
cataclysmic event people became space
refugees and my this is my personal
hypothesis now now I'm going to my
hypothesis mode that they left those
areas and those regions and went into
new sectors to create Breakaway
civilizations kind of a fresh start and
Earth one of them and I've seen you kind
of um looking at satellite images from
other planets where you look at in
detail unusual structures for example
but have you I've heard from David ikim
saying the word Nibiru was a possible
Planet they came from do you have an
idea of where these people came
from yeah so that's a good question
neiru and anunaki are two terms that
people say don't exist but they're
mentioned in the enum is so we know
those terms and those words are real
words but some of them came from sirious
star system some came from the pades
some came from Al debron some came from
the Epsilon BST constellation so there
was a varying different array of planets
that these people all came from when
they spread out from the plees they
literally populated many stars they
actually actually have the power to
travel from star to star something that
we're supposed to be able to do now but
with all the suppression and oppression
we hav't able to get there but so we're
talking about a multi-racial
multiplanetary species that created an
Atlantean civilization that's the name
they are they're all Anunnaki because
that means from those from Heaven came
to Earth but they created an an
Atlantean civilization on Earth and
Earth was Atlantis not just a ring City
in the Atlantic Ocean yeah that was just
one capital of dozens that existed but
the entire planet itself was Atlantis
and I believe Atlantis was even in this
solar system an interplanetary
civilization as well yeah so when people
say where did Atlantis go we're we're on
it essentially we're on it we're all
standing and sitting on it right now and
and and how advanced uh you know let's
if we were to put a time frame on it how
how how more much more advanced
technologically were they than us right
now well if you to look at where we are
right now as a species they were
approximately 1 million years ahead of
us which is a big number and reason why
I calculate this and how I come up with
this this is a hypothesis this is not
stated in any record but when you look
at the fact that we're talking about
approximately 450,000 years ago they
arrived initially the first Pantheon the
pantheon doesn't come out of Greece and
the pantheon was a Samaran Pantheon and
that first Pantheon arrived uh that
you're talking about 450,000 now they
worked and labored themselves for
250,000 years without interacting or
engaging the the existing homonid on the
planet which was actually our cousins
before we were Homo sapiens sapien they
didn't engage in genetic manipulation
until about 200,000 years ago which
geneticists can align with that their
statements in their peer-review
documents can align that chromosome
number two was taken out infused
together and telare caps were put on
them approximately 200,000 years ago and
geneticist and universities are saying
that was an artificial mutation well the
Samaran records are telling us exactly
how it happened these people did it to
us to create Homo sapiens sapien and
make us into the workers so they can
stop working it was a big war that was
going to happen there was a coup that
was going to happen in the atraes and
they said no we'll get these beings to
do the work for us and that's when the
genetic man manipulation happened but so
450,000 years they've already can travel
from star to star to star that means
they had been super Advanced for a very
very long time the technology that they
had back then at 200,000 450,000 years
ago we aren't even close to cracking
that code we still have no clue we only
have 10,000 hypothesis about how the
pyramid was built we still flying around
in uh you know in planes that are using
fossil fuel we got cars on fos we're
trying to go to hydrogen now because EVS
are are no good but we're not even close
we're not even in in a vicinity they had
mastered the ability to combine
spirituality with technology so they
took spiritual Essence which is the
power of conscious thought and they were
able to now mix that with technology
giving them an unbelievable array of
different types of quote unquote powers
that to us were Godlike uh and so we're
not even close to that level so just to
break it down into layman's terms for
people who've been you know we've all
heard Darwin's theory of evolution at
school for example how how would you say
the real story goes as opposed to that
yeah yeah as opposed to Darwin which
Darwin actually admitted himself that he
didn't fully believe in his own Theory
before he died so here a fact but they
never say that little extra part at the
end in college right but what we're
talking about here is an advanced race
of beings that came to this planet at
the time where mankind of a ver a
different version of us still look the
same probably bigger bones bigger Jaws
we found much bigger skulls around this
entire planet so we know that we were we
look different probably much smarter
spiritually and um and consciously um
but nonetheless we were here uh and then
at some point this war was going to
happen in South Africa at a place called
Adam's Calendar and an agreement was
made to add their Essence to the
existing being here which was our cousin
so they genetically modified us and then
from there we became the worker so they
tried at first this cloning technique
which I took people to see the evidence
of this cloning at the kambo and the
carck temple so they can see evidence in
the walls of hieroglyphs the cloning
technique uh Temple of hathor where they
had the birthing houses for the Clones
the problem that they had with the
cloning techniques was according to the
text these beings couldn't replicate on
their own it was too much labor again
just to try to create a population of
workers so Isis says you know what I've
had it I'm going to do something
different I'm going to take the baby to
term myself and so she takes an egg from
an existing homid she uh adds their
Essence to that egg she puts it in her
own womb now we're talking about now
scientifically something called a zygote
or we're talking about vro fertilization
back then she takes the baby to term for
10 months and there's a famous cylinder
scroll in a British museum with her
holding up the baby she calls it the
adamu which means first man and she's
saying my hands have created it that was
the first genetically modified version
of perfection for a self-replicating
human being Homo sapiens sapien was now
born and then this is where you get in
the Bible Genesis the generations of
Isis genisis right and so they yeah
that's where it comes from
yeah ad as in Adam and Eve right yes
Adam and Eve right exactly now when Adam
was born there were already hundreds of
thousands of people on the planet maybe
even more than that and so he wasn't the
first man you can't get eight billion
people from two people and if anybody
doesn't believe that just start mating
your son and daughter with each other
and see how many generations you can get
out of that before a oneeyed crippled
person comes out right so you have to be
like okay wait a minute not enough
genetic diversity two people can't
create 8 billion so he they started
mating him with these clones the Clones
still couldn't get pregnant so then they
said okay we got to take a sample so
they took a sample of DNA from him
created Eve made it them Bingo it worked
Adam and Eve weren't the first one so
they said now we got to make a whole a
whole slew of these people so they
started doing that making these uh you
know in the ha or birthing houses they
started giving birth to adamus and EES
and then now they growing them up and
now they're they're mating them together
they're creating genetic diversity and
they're creating a population of people
that can replicate on their own the
evidence of this is when Cain kills Abel
he he uh God comes back it's actually
Yahweh which is actually in liil from
the Samaran tablets and he says what's
going on here now you you're God you
should already know what's going on here
but he obviously kills his brother out
of out of jealousy he kicks him out of
the garden and Cain says the people out
there will kill me well what people
there shouldn't be anybody out there and
then God says don't worry I put a mark
on your head so you know they'll know
I'mma brand you so they'll know you're
my boy nobody's going to touch you so
don't worry about it and when you get
out there by the way the Bible says
you'll find a wife see so there was
people many many many many people living
outside and he goes off to start the
whole Canaanites but uh there's many
people living before adamy but still the
the religion still pushed two came out
of two out of two people comes the
entire population which is fake
news so so these people who were here
before who are big basically relatives
to what we are now um who created them I
guess and and how did they get are they
just that's a great
question you see these people mentioned
several times in the tablets that what
they had done here they knew was wrong
they were operating like you know the
old ww west so they were doing things
that were according to them I forget the
exact terminology but they were saying
that their laws from where they had come
from like they were violating those laws
they said they will have to answer to
the creator of all and they say this a
couple times in some of these tablets so
that means from their perspective there
is somebody that created all and they're
aware of this so even though they
masquerad as gods and pretended to be
God and you know Satan the Lord of Eden
that's actually in liil who becomes
Yahweh in the modern day bible uh these
people acted as gods and and pretended
to be gods and made the people worship
them and bring them all their the
offerings were so they can have food to
eat these people aren't going to go
hunting anywhere bring me your V
vegetables and fruits and bring me that
damn land because I'm hungry you know
what I'm saying and so uh this why there
are storehouses for all the offerings at
all these ancient temples that I go
visit because they would actually dump
all that food in there and then these
people would get you know the the
priests would cook the food for these
these fake Gods but so that's what's
going on that's what happened The more
I've looked into it the more it seems a
bit more likely than you know water into
the wine and some of the other stories
in the Bible um and um in terms of the
powers that we've had you know we've
this version of human and the previous
version of human do you think we've ever
had been more powerful almost to like a
supernatural level of of
ability oh I I really do believe that I
believe that we're the I don't want to
yeah I don't like to use the word dumb
down but we're the the version that's
got to find itself no it's it's still in
us well we've got to now tap back into
what we already had in ancient times I
believe that our cousins were tapped in
deeper spiritually probably can
communicate with telepathy right
probably had a lot more psychic
abilities deeper EMP empathic abilities
also and right now human beings homo
saan we have billions of magnetite
crystals in our brains and we don't even
sense that they're there but they took a
they took a human being put him in a
room with a giant bar magnet put sensors
on his head connected it to a computer
and when they move the bar magnet the
crystals reorient to the magnet's
magnetic field so should still
hypothetically should still be able to
navigate by the Earth's magnetic field
like turtles and birds and everything
else but we we've lost we've been so
disconnected from that uh you know from
that uh natural ability that we think is
something special when somebody has
these innate abilities we think oh man
they're special they they got gifts no
we're all we all have gifts we just
forgot how to open our packages and you
know all of the stuff that they had
we're supposed to be able to tap into as
well we have now junk DNA which is not
junk scientists are just now finding out
that that really acts on the body and
acts on it activates and turns off and
on genes so now they're trying to figure
out what what genes does it turn off and
turn on and how do we get that back
activated again so we kind of really
been disconnected from who we truly are
uh we have the power in us because it's
talked about in the myth of adapa which
is an ancient tablet that we were
created even greater than the anunaki
themselves but that we would have to go
on a a hero's journey of self-discovery
to get back to it so how's this memory
reset taking place like how have we
forgotten so much of this great question
when you begin to oppress and suppress
people's knowledge and their and their
history it robs the future generation of
the information so the best thing the
the best way to steal the knowledge of
who somebody really is is to
continuously change their information
you look at the Tower of Babylon inent
where yah comes back who's actually in
liil and he sees that human beings are
building this Tower into heaven
duplicating a tower that's called a Doon
key that the anagi had built they
duplicated it and he goes oh my goodness
whatever they can whatever they set
their hearts to they can achieve it he
said wow this is too powerful my seed
shall not abide in Man Forever his year
shall be 120 so the first thing he did
was he genetically modified chromosome
number two and knocked us down to 120
year Max what does Harvard scientist say
the maximum lifespan of a human being
120 years under pristine conditions the
next thing he did was he's divided
people and separated and Confused our
languages now I don't know I can't talk
to Jesus Jesus can't talk to Wang d wend
d can't talk you know what I'm saying so
now all of a sudden we got all these
different races and languages going on
and we can't really communicate so we
can't collaborate our lifes spans are
short but by the time we wake up it's
time to die and we go right back into
the cycle and start all over again so
they found a way to do that and then
keep covering up the ancient history
keep covering up the real truth about
who we are where we came from and after
generation after generation
it becomes a a civilization of just
people walking around with amnesia right
like Graham Hancock says yeah and and
Graham hanok particularly points to the
great cataclysms as part of the reason
as well of this reset that happened
where we're all sort of one minute you
know Advanced civilization and then
right back to square one and starting
again um and do you feel like that's
part of the reason too that has that's
also a part of the reason you look at
the younger dest incident right so you
have the younger dest you're talking
about right around the you know the Ice
Age so now we're going back 12 13,000
years all of a sudden this gigantic
asteroid crashes in uh to the Earth
right above Syria and all this ice melt
happens and all this ice turns into
water now you've got a regional
globalized flood not a global flood but
a regional flood in a part of the in a
part of the Globe coming all the way
down even out through Egypt where the
Sphinx is and the evidence of this
younger dran is at is in the Sphinx
enclosure where you can clearly see the
water damage you can see how much water
has passed through on the walls of the
enclosure and you can almost tell how
many years it's taken for that to that
erosion to happen you're talking about
right around the same time as the
younger D Dr Younger dest incident and
so we're talking about a situation where
we have physical evidence that this
water flowed down from this younger D
and flooded out the entire region there
where the Great Sphinx is located at
Giza and it's clear clear evidence that
the Sphinx is not four or 5,000 years
old because if it was how did this water
damage happen to a man-made built-
enclosure that predates the Ice Age so
we're you know we're talking about the
Spinx is much older and again more
evidence that the history books are not
accurate yeah that sort of brings us
onto the pyramids which I I've always
been fascinated by and always found very
difficult to understand how they were
built by the people even in school when
I was like I don't know eight years old
I was like this doesn't
okay um but you you said like there's
water damage there so do you know
roughly what we can date the water
damage to yeah roughly around 12 to
13,000 years and that's coming from a
professor geologist Ro Dr Robert shock
we're talking about you know a person
who's still teaching in college right
now a real geologist that went to the
university for that particular field
that's looking at this is saying No this
evidence is pointing to here and has
taken samples and everything and because
of his I guess his dating of the age of
this and being very um vocal about it
he's pretty much banned from going back
to Egypt and when it comes to the
pyramids I mean uh Graeme Hancock did a
great job of explaining how
unexplainable from his point of view it
is that such massive heavy Stones would
be up so high and um he famously said if
if that was a ramp you need a
big ramp and it still be there to this
day so you know you and I know that
you've set up tours for the pyramid and
you've got such an interest in that so
what is your opinion of who built them
how they were built and all of that M
wow the pyramid first of all when you
stand next to the Great Pyramid time
slows down because it's time dilation
bubble they knew all of this stuff I
mean the Great Pyramid itself is a
gigantic multi-functional Stone computer
and power generator it's got multiple
functions and so when you begin to
analyze it as a technological device not
as a monument all of a sudden all these
question marks start popping up and when
you begin to start looking for answers
to those question marks and start
studying engineering books you start to
see that we're looking at a real machine
a real machine and it's so ingenious how
they built this there's a couple ways
that it could happen first of all it
never was a mud ramp mud ramps is is a
complete farce because you would need
more mass than the pyramid in
mud yeah that's not gonna happen right
you're not going to if you and when you
stand next to these megalithic blocks
you're going to realize you can't put
them on top of tree log you got to go
get the tree logs from turkey and bring
them all the way down to Egypt and you
got to get these stones and put them on
top and roll them into sand I mean come
on more ridiculous the more asinine it
begins to sound but when you start to
look at some of the writings and you
hear that th talks about a couple
different things first it was a quarry
that they used to harvest some of these
stones and you can see that you can
witness it you can go there and see that
they obviously had some type of gravity
control system which Alters the atomic
uh uh structure or the vi or the the the
orientation I'm sorry of the atoms in
the stone to get it to be extremely
light not weightless but much lighter
that's number one number two F talks
about combining photons or light he says
light with frequency simatic frequencies
now that sounds like you know magic but
two years ago in a university in Europe
two scientists got together and for the
first time they Ed photons and
vibrations to create solid matter
so we're just now rediscovering what
already happened in ancient times so
some of these stones are manifested at
those says through light waves and
frequencies and some are harvested
depending on the usage and what was
being done another thing that's
interesting is if you look at the
construction of the Great Pyramid you
begin to realize that it's also an
astronomical time piece and what it does
is it breaks down the distance from the
Earth to the Moon the distance from the
Earth to the Sun the circumference of
the the Sun the circum of the earth it's
also a scale down model of Earth itself
if you scale it up 43,200 times it fits
inside the earth perfectly and touches
all corners and it also by calculating
the stones it it can give you the the
days in the year the tropical year the
siderial year it can give you the speed
of our sun around the Milky Way galaxy
and even the speed of our galaxy around
the local clusters and when you analyze
Giza from above you realize that it's a
star chart of the inner solar system
planets okay so you're talking about
Mercury Venus Earth and Mars with the
sun in the middle and then also you
begin to realize man wait a minute
what's going on here this thing really
is giving you the average height of
every Peak on Earth the average height
to do that today we would need a
satellite orbiting in a polar orbit as
the Earth spins on its axis we would be
scanning and taping topographical data
stitching it together sending it into a
computer that computer will now count
all the all the and then divide them to
get the average height now that means
they had some type of satellite
technology and then they Incorporated
all of that into the Great Pyramid so
we're talking about a super Advanced
race of space fearing people not people
that were slaves and and all this other
you know chicken bones and copper
chisels all this crazy elephants with
tree log rollers and mud that's all a
farce yeah and it it's funny because I
know people who' have actually just been
in the pyramid and and inside just for
tour and said it feels like you're in a
machine it doesn't feel like you're in a
an object that was designed to have tour
guides take you through like they
literally had a force stays there and
then it's not comfortable and it isn't
made for that it clearly is you know um
so what do you make of the fact that
like the Egyptians themselves who kind
of moved in so to speak have then kind
of etched their um signature on someone
else's work and apparently they've
redone the faces on the Sphinx and stuff
they do you think that they are taking
credit for what came
before no doubt about it the dynastic
Egyptians inherited what was already
there the Mayan culture inherited what
was already there the Aztecs who came
later than the Mayans inherited what was
already there and left behind by the
Mayans who were left who found what was
left behind by the Tans which means the
city of Tudi which means the city of th
in meso America so all these cultures
inherited existing ancient megalithic
structures and advanced cities that were
left behind after the after this thing
called the second pyramid War where they
released weapons that they called
weapons of mass destruction
wmds that were hidden in the mountain
that hidden in the mountain that were
forbidden to be used based on what had
happened on their home planet in ancient
times in their ancient times somebody
smuggled them to this planet when they
when they evacuated and hit him in the
mountain and eventually a future
generation offspring of that person
decided to use them in a war and they
created something called the evil wind
which swept across the land and kill the
kill the black-faced people it says
that's the exact term it says the
blackface people died the animals died
people's hair and nails were falling out
eyes were bleeding you're talking about
radiation poisoning you're talking about
radiation sick sickness so we're talking
about evidence of an ancient war that
happened so this all it all comes
together all begins to make a lot of
sense when you start looking at all
these little facts and piecing all the
puzzle together you see what really
happened in the ancient past I I think
the hardest thing for just regular
people like myself to wrap my head
around is we automatically think we are
here now therefore we must be the most
advanced thing that's ever existed and
and and just to sort of forget that is
the is the healthiest way to sort of
digest this information and uh you know
I've seen you talking about some of
those um structures around the pyramids
and that look like launch pads um yeah
and that that was quite a fascinating
thing as well and so so just just so I'm
clear you think that the is it the
anunaki specifically are responsible for
the
pyramids yeah I think that the anaraki
specifically who are actually the
Atlantean culture are responsible for
the pyramids in the in the emerald tab
th comes to the land of Kemet he lands
his ship he descends from the sky down
near an ancient Temple that's coming up
out of the mud so it's not a ship that's
sailing on the ocean clearly that mean
it's very clear then his crew that he
took with them come there to help him
rebuild the land of chem they say they
said they stayed there for a time and
time again so they stayed it for a very
long time to rebuild once they got it
rebuilt he tells his crew that he
brought with him to spread out around
the planet and duplicate what we did
here so all of a sudden pyramids and
civilization pop up out of nowhere
worldwide have you seen pyramid the
pyramid that's well they they haven't
UNC it because it's covered in Earth but
there's a gigantic pyramid I've seen in
a video on recently where it you can see
it from a satellite do you know which
one I'm on about uh it's the one I'm
going to go see actually in December
right um it it looks gigantic and that
clearly those right angles they they
don't look like they were created by
Nature it looks like a pyramid hidden
underneath the Earth right oh yeah for
sure and they just found over 200
pyramids buried in the Sands of Giza
with ground penetrating radar from a
satellite wow so they're everywhere and
if you go to heard that they were in
Antarctica from or something like that
right oh Antarctica they're everywhere
and the antarctican pyramid is the super
megalithic it makes the the Great
Pyramid look like it's tiny right it's a
super massive pyramid supposedly there's
still some some type of exotic energy
coming out of that you go into the
Atlantic Ocean the center of the berer
triangle there's a pyramid down there
still exist still emitting some type of
exotic energy from the Apex
that's what is the cause for all of
these disappearances and anomalies and
time anomalies and everything else if
you take a line and you were able to go
down to the center of that Apex and draw
a line straight through the center of
the Bermuda Triangle and come out on the
other side of the earth you come out at
the Devil's Triangle right at the
yonaguni pyramid in Japan the dragons
triangle I'm sorry where there's also
been disappearances and all kind of
apparitions and so forth so we're
talking about an
interconnected uh grid of pyramids that
also dup duplicated or also um had a job
for as portals or wormholes or something
that connected different places on Earth
people would go from one place to
another almost instantaneously kind of
like teleportation all this stuff was
happening in the ancient past in my
personal opinion yeah when you showed me
the bird's eye view from above the
Egyptian pyramids and how the solar
system fits perfectly onto that that was
where I was like yeah you didn't do that
by accident like no it is mind it is
mindblowing stuff here and
you I want to move on to the Bible a
little bit because there was you know I
I grew up here in little bible stories
at school innocently just yeah okay that
sounds cool um and when but when you
start telling me like yeah some of this
has really been copied from like word
for word almost from thousands of years
ago from other scriptures and and stuff
that you've been reading so um so Adam
and Eve you kind of covered that Adam
and Eve were the first of many of this
new version of us so that is kind of
true
yeah absolutely so yeah they're they're
the new version they're the ones that
okay now they can uh they can made it on
their own so if you start reading these
texts you find out that the Garden of
Eden was like a giant laboratory but
there was like a mating uh house like
how you have horses and and stalls and
you make them at certain times of the
day we were being treated like animals
like literally they would have men on
one side and women on the other side and
then there were specific mating times
and you got in trouble if you didn't
make at the right time and if you tried
to mate out of your turn you also got in
trouble what's interesting is there's
guards at the gate in the Bible there's
guards at the gate in the book of Adam
which is an Apocrypha text left out of
the Bible there's guards at the gate in
the Sumerian Tablets what in the hell do
we need guards for with weapons they all
have weapons why would they have weapons
what are they doing there why does God
need guards with weapons when he can
just think things into existence you see
when you start analyzing this for what
it really is you begin to realize wait a
minute something else is going on why do
they call Yahweh Satan the Lord of Eden
Ed iin in the ancient text because he
really is Satan that's why that's why my
most famous video that I did is you know
could the god of the Bible be Satan I
break it all the way down you know so
we're talking about two people that were
just the two the first two of the most
genetically modified for the per for the
purpose of mating creating and building
a slavery race on this planet that means
everyone on this planet was a slave and
now a word from our sponsors I want to
thank our sponsor ground news the best
place to do your research for anything
even UFOs apparently now this website is
super easy to use and they give you
different viewpoints on all of the news
so when you search a topic they take
news stories from all over the Internet
and put them into one nice and easy to
use list they give you key info on who
the Publishers are what their political
biases are and how factual their
reporting practice are which is really
important so when I searched UFOs
they've given me over 300 articles here
and they actually have this really great
feature called the media bias breakdown
of this topic in general and you can see
it's very evenly split left 33 Center 35
the right 32% which is fine for UFOs but
let's say you're searching news on
Donald Trump that media bias breakdown
is going to really help you understand
why people are saying what they're
saying and what direction they're really
coming from so let's take for example
scientists called fraud on Aliens
presented at Mexican Congress which is a
bit gutten if I'm honest I was hoping
they were real you can see the breakdown
here of the total new sources how many
are leaning left how many are leaning
right and the center when it was last
updated and the bias distribution of 60%
Central and they even show you exactly
where these new sources sit within the
political sway obviously one of the most
important things for me is the
factuality of these articles and you can
see here 85% which is considered high
which means we're getting reliable news
here and in particular with UFOs you
want to know like is this an independent
writer or are they employed by the
government and as you can see it even
shows it here the government of
Singapore for example wrote this article
so you're completely clued up from
ground news from the ground up so big
thanks to ground news you can be a
subscriber to them now and get the
highest quality news possible by
clicking the link in the description
below that's ground. news/ TG and you
can get your subscription for as little
as $1 a month or you can take advantage
of their biggest sale of the year
through my link for 40% off Advantage
which is the subscription I have the
link is in the description below thanks
to them but for now enjoy the podcast
David Ike definitely touched on a little
bit of that in our interview where he
said like I think people are worshiping
the wrong God you know like if you look
at the way God is depicted in the Old
Testament and the things he comes out
with is that a benevolent soft loving
caring God like you'd want to believe
him to be not really um no David said to
me it's the gods you you need to
remember that and by gods we mean the
aliens who are actually in control um in
terms of Jesus you've talked a little
bit about the the real story of Jesus
can you talk a bit more about that and
explain that to me please sure
absolutely first of all Jesus his name
is his real name is Yeshua right Yeshua
that's his real name uh and he was a
real person an actual real physical
person because some people think maybe
it was just a myth no it wasn't a myth
it was a real person now a some of the
things attributed to him were um kind of
out there because they got taken out of
context and remix but when he uh turned
you know from the age of 12 to 32 he
disappears from the biblical text he's
he's gone missing right so where does he
go well he ends up in Egypt and I just
took 130 people just a few weeks ago to
the place where he actually laid his
head it's a shrine there in Egypt and
there's a map there that shows all the
places that him and his mother visited
while in Egypt and stayed as they were
hiding from the Romans and so uh in
Egypt he was learning the Egyptian
Mysteries okay this and then he leaves
there eventually at some point he heads
to Tibet and then he's now learning
chiong and Reiki and all these other
energy healings and so forth with his
hands and that's been confirmed by the
Dal Lama then he's coming down back in
through India learning the Mystic Arts
and he's teaching reincarnation all the
way back and if anybody really reads the
Book of Revelation they realize that
it's a reincarnation story of of Flesh
and Blood because it says you're coming
back in a real body not not some light
body you're going to be in a real body
and you're going to have a new name it's
a reincarnation story but but
nonetheless he's teaching this um and he
so he was a real person in my opinion he
could have been learning the ancient
mysteries from th the Atlantean which is
who who was the originator of the
mystery schools number one that had
lasted for so many thousands of years
but also there's another possibility
it's just a
hypothesis this being talks about being
able to Incarnate at will he talks about
using bodies to come back bodies that he
clones himself or creates himself he
says he creates these bodies to come
back in and walk around could he somehow
say you know what I'd like to know what
is it like to have the Human Experience
and allows himself to come back through
the womb of a human being uh retaining
full memory so that he can have the
experience of coming through the womb
and suffering as what we call call a
normal person or what he call what he
used to call the little people right
it's a possibility just a hypothesis
something to ponder or think about but
it's pretty inter that Mary's mother was
also a virgin birth so she's also in vro
fertilization where where did you hear
that Mary was also a virgin birth that's
in the Apocrypha text wow so when you
read the Apocrypha you begin to find us
out if you read the gospel of the Holy
12 you find out where Jesus Jesus
disappeared to when he disappears from
the Bible the gospel of the Holy 12
again they accidentally on purpose left
this information out of the Bible too
yeah they do seem to have been selected
from everything I'm learning about what
you're saying it's it it seems like they
picking and choose what sort of matches
up with the story they want to tell so
in regards to the story of is Jesus the
son of
God you think he may be connected in
some way to um uh thorth when they say
God they're talking about these people
and and David Ike was right Gods with an
S because in the Bible everywhere where
you see the word god singular that's a
Mis transation by accident on purpose
the original term is Gods with an S and
Elohim is also plural Gods so we're
talking about gods and we're not talking
anywhere in that Bible about the creator
of the actual universe itself nowhere
does it ever mention the real creator of
the universe that book is about Flesh
and Blood people men that put their
pants on one leg at a time just like you
and me uh so it's really unfortunate but
these Gods these people were Advanced
they had Advanced knowledge Advanced
spiritual Concepts advanced
technology uh and so that's who these
people were learning from and you know
in my father's house there are many
mansions well there's in my opinion
there's super duper massive spaceships
in in uh you know in outer space yeah I
I just think that he was part human part
anunaki more like a quote unquote
demigod in my opinion but what's
interesting is a very small text was
found years ago called The Book of
Jesus's wife which is located at the
Harvard Seminary so and in the sinine
Bible he was never crucified I think
that's a fabrication made up by the
Roman Church uh you know they added
their p Doctrine and everything else to
the Bible too so they can say you know
what we're tired of fighting these
people let's just go collaborate with
them and collect all the money we'll
take the tithes and offerings and we'll
give them to taxes so we'll double dip
on them they they'll be so dumb they
won't even realize it and that's what
happened yeah so the the Roman Catholic
Church have basically rework the story
so that it sounds nicer for them yeah U
and if I'm not mistaken Jesus the
physical version of Jesus that we see uh
in Brazil for example he didn't really
look like that he no
yeah that's a Pope's son that that face
that's that's Caesar
bourier Caesar bourier who was a
murdering killer who was sleeping with
his sister killed his brother because he
won his brother's power and rights to
rule and so forth underneath his dad who
was a pope and he ordered uh all the
paintings to be you know to have his
face to be depicted as him and it just
caught on and it continued on for
obviously till this current day but yeah
I mean yeah the real Yeshua was a middle
eastern or African and not not the the
depiction that we see so even in that
people are praying to a False Image you
know the Bible says don't pray pray to
false gods yet they're praying to a man
I mean a real man and also uh they're
praying to His Image which is not even a
right image so that's even a false image
and then they're calling on his name
which is not even his name the Jay is a
recent letter the Jay was in like the
1500s I believe or something 1540 or
whatever it was don't quote me exactly
but Jay wasn't there they're they're
they're they're screaming out isus which
means hail Zeus this is why calling on
that name has no real power you know
he's not even you're not even calling on
the per you know the person who's
supposed to be the god the Son of God
and what he
says we're all worshiping a guy who who
murdered someone essentially um they're
murdering a guy who who murdered
somebody and they're calling on Zeus
yeah at the same time so their their
prayers are all mixed up they have no
they have no power if you if you look at
the state of the world today you
calculate 85% of the world is Christian
85% and all those prayers are going up
night in Night Out day in day out
trillions of prayers a day because
people are praying multiple times a day
times by billions all of a sudden you
begin to realize these prayers ain't
being answered we should be living in
the golden age right now yeah how come
the Golden Age isn't happening and when
you say because these prayers aren't
working and when you say we're saying
instead of Jesus means here Zeus uh Zeus
being one of the anunaki I'm assuming
one of the anunaki yeah anunaki like
those those Greek gods and all of that
this is this kind of what we're
referring to as well in that sense yes
the Greek gods are the old are the old
anunaki are you know the newer version
of the anoi pantheon so to speak so you
know you just convert their names over
from from from suan and they all took
them over and converted them into Greek
names you know like Mercury is actually
th for example right Poseidon is so you
got you start to see this correlation
between the're they're still talking
about the pantheon of Greek Greece is
still talking about the anaki and people
are still praying to these anunaki Gods
till this very day matter of fact every
time you say Amen you're praying you're
saying thank you to amenra who's also
known as Marduk that's in the Jewish
Torah that's in the Bible you can look
up the name just do a search on that
name m m a r d UK K oh wow then you find
out that's Marduk is actually Aman raah
from
ancient Egypt and he ordered that every
person give thanks under his name you
know when uh when they pray or anything
that they get so it's really am moon but
it became amen much later obviously over
iterations of verb verbes and people
people speaking but you're giving thanks
to a brutal killing murdering ruler
every time you say Amen this is why
people have no idea cuz when you're
praying you're trying to cast a spell
that's really what it is you want to
alter your reality to your benefit by
saying these words to a Dei on the
outside of you and you're hoping that
something magical happens and turns
thing around that's casting a spell but
you can't even cast a spell right
because you're calling on deed these
that don't have any
power it it is quite amazing when you
think we've all been saying like I
remember being a little kid at school
saying oh man like you know you pray you
know when they tell you and I I never
thought why am I saying the words amen
like ever and you've mentioned Satan or
Satan um a few times now what can you
tell me about him well he's an evil dude
his name is actually en liil from the
ancient Samaran tablets if you read the
Epic of Gilgamesh and the or the book of
Deuteronomy in the Bible you're going to
go oh my goodness this is who I've been
praying to this guy would say in the
Epic of vgames human beings the humans
are making too much clamor they're just
too loud go kill them off so he would
send his military out to go kill like
hundreds or even thousands of humans to
get it more Qui quiet outside to a
little too much noise or he would say
the people over here he had this thing
called an allseeing eye that can let him
see population densities on the planet
okay on a crystal tablet he calls it he
says you know people over here they're
just they're just unruly he would send
his people to go spray their crops and
dry them out so now we're talking about
Chemtrails in Samaran tablets so they
can starve to death just starve them to
death they'll shut up now right and then
he would even spread plagues he would
have them go spread plagues to kill so
we're talking about a brutal evil dude
uh and so he didn't like what happened
when th I'm sorry when his brother enki
enki th is enki's son when enki uh went
into the Garden of Eden and started
talking to these people and telling them
how powerful they are and that they have
that you know that they're not animals
that they deserve the right to walk
around with respect and dignity just
like us because we're we're the same
that was the Apple that they ate the
apple was knowledge Apple represents
knowledge
and so when he came back uh and Li he
realizes what's happened that his
brother interacted with them so he made
a decree that his brother is a devil his
my he's don't worship Him don't talk to
him this guy's evil to keep him from
getting in everyone's air and waking
them up so but the true Satan the true
devil is Yahweh which is in liil so the
guy in the in the Bible who says you
know don't listen to the snake he's the
real problem right the snake is is
wisdom in all ancient texts the snake
always represents wisdom but you see how
they Twisted it snakes you're a snake
you're crawling on your belly you're
this deceiver no snakes in ancient Egypt
in the dynastic era in Mayan everywhere
else you go snake is representing wisdom
and this is also kind of assume how God
seems to twist personality throughout
the Bible as they're picking and
choosing from different gods and that's
why there's no consistency there and
that's why they're battling they're
fighting they they got so uh so much ego
they started fighting over each other
fighting each other over resources and
humans so who who can who can rule over
the most humans who can get the most
praise from their for the the humans
that they're ruling over and they
started going to war over this stuff and
the Book of Deuteronomy in the Bible you
see one God because you could tell it's
two or three different gods speaking you
go to this town and and you go with my
angels now angels are putting on the
breast plates in battle and getting all
kind of weapons out why do angels need
weapons and why are they going to fight
with humans go to this city one person
there has something against me and so I
want you to kill everyone in the entire
city kill the women kill the children
you're talking about killing babies now
they say even Slaughter the the the
animals if you want to and they say if
you find some virgins by the way you can
bring them back bring the virgins back
this is in the book of Deuteronomy a man
if you see a woman walking across the
field you can rape her but if you rape
her now you got a choice you can keep
her or you can you know you can tell her
to go or you can keep her as a wife now
you got rape and abduction false
imprisonment you know and then you get
all these stupid battles going back and
forth go to this town and smite everyone
and bring The Spoils of War back to me
why does God the creator of the universe
need Spoils of War why does he need that
you see we're talking about real people
we're not talking about the creator of
the universe because the creator of the
universe doesn't have time to get
involved in Petty Wars of ants we're
just like ants I'm not going to The Ant
heill and going I wonder if this red ant
is against that red ant let me kick this
red ant Hill so this red an can have a
benefit of it I mean come on and I
suppose that's why when when we talk
about sacrifices to the
gods you know that's what they're really
referring to is the these real
people who are actually happy to accept
them yeah um oh yeah and and yeah I've
definitely seen so-called Gods depicted
with battle arm Maron and and even going
back to um some hieroglyphics I've seen
where like basically animals SL people
look like they're in flying objects and
you're like well what was going on there
then um in terms of um other Bible
stories are there any others that you've
uncovered where you're like oh this this
has some truth in it but it was this
like Noah AR for example anything like
that or no AR is pretty interesting
because when you look at the biblical
account it seems that the the dimensions
make it into what we would call a
ship
but uh you look at the information
released about six years ago it's at the
British museum they found a lost tablet
this tablet talks about uh zurra who's
really Noah in the modern day bible
getting the order and the decree to
build this ship and the dimensions of
the ship is like a dis not a ship that
sails across the ocean something totally
different he was also told not to gather
two of every kind on the entire planet
don't get these two cockroaches because
it's going to come in handy no
he was told to gather your local your
local cattle and your local you know
animals and things like that some of the
Flora and Fauna some seeds or whatever
and he put those on the on the on the
round submersible or maybe it flew
nobody really knows but it was round and
it's it's depicted there it's very clear
to see it was a Round Disc not a sailing
ship pretty interesting uh and then when
you look at the Samaran tablet you
discover that this strike of this
asterid that created this Global flood
was avoidable by the anunaki but that
enl was so pissed off about all the
knowledge and wisdom and all the
inspiration that had been given by his
brother enki and his nephew th and a few
others he said I'm going to wipe out the
entire planet and we're going to start
over again uh and he had that power
because he was the ranking ruler over
even his own family members it says that
they had watched from their Sky Abode
and and they mned their creation being
destroyed so they watched this from
space so essentially Satan or an enl did
you say sorry um he he kind of all he
allowed this to happen to create a reset
because he was unhappy with the way
things were going yeah so I'm going
start fresh let's start all over again
and that's where the emerald tabis picks
up though is given a decree by his
father yeah who's enki he's also known
as th me to go to the land of Kim and
rebuild them to a high level of
civilization so he sneaks his son in and
says hey man let's let's get this thing
cranking again let's get it going again
start teaching these people and as soon
as th lands his ship there The
Barbarians come to attack him so you can
see how far back we had fallen again all
the way to a barbaric stage and he says
that he raised his staff and he sends
out a ray of vibration which stopped him
steal a stone of the mountain so he has
some type of a a non-lethal vibration
weapon that breathes with them in their
tracks and then he goes over to begin to
talking to them they start grabbling at
his feet and he says no stand up I'm a
son of Atlantis he didn't say I'm a Son
of God he didn't say I am God he said
I'm a son of Atlantis I'm here to bring
you back up to a high level of
civilization and he begins to talk peace
with them and they talk about rebuilding
and they begin to put their plans
together to rebuild so he essentially
seems like a force of good and and part
of uh you know even though he was anun
he was now Earth Earthling essentially
yeah
um I assume the the question from the
audience will be well if they've been
here before are they still here now and
if so where are they yeah I think that
they are still here now there's a tablet
which talks about after that War I told
you about a lot of them left some stayed
and I believe that their offspring are
still walking your planet till this very
day I still I also still believe there
are some very very powerful ones
operating behind the veil that are
controlling the governments of this
World a very small faction that are
still pulling the strings and
controlling every war every outcome uh
and trying to you know keep their grasp
on the planet that's evolving and
changing in in in not only in mass of
civilization but also in technology and
that they're going to soon lose that
grip as the age of Aquarius is upon us
and these beings only ruled by Star
Charts it's very interesting that you
bring up star science because I was
actually going to bring that up at some
point because um they are wholeheartedly
opposed by religion it's seems and
viewed as devil worship style stuff yeah
uh what is your opinion of their
significance to us super significant
you're going back to the time of Horus
from ancient Kemet long before it was
the dynastic era he's one of the Nuru
right uh and so Horus which is where you
get the word horoscope it comes from
Horus from ancient Egypt and so this
gave gave us the ability to understand
months and movements of stars and
alignments and everything else it's
really important because when you look
at star charts and you look at um
astrology which I used to think was
maybe not real when I started to look
into science and gravitational fields I
realized there is some truth to
astrology and there's probably a lot of
fake ones out there but there are some
ones that are probably pretty spoton
when I lo looked at some scientific
studies where they took um Frog's eggs
into space and they begin to let them
mature let the embryos mature and hatch
not hatch but you know grow into frogs
they they were realizing something
incredible that the magnetic field of
the earth and the pull of the moon were
having effect on whether they were male
or female and so this experiment was
done a few more times and they began to
realize that magnetic fields and
gravitational fields
alter uh the the genes inside of an
embryo in the embryotic stage now when
you look at star charts and alignments
if you're born under a specific
alignment on a specific day that field
that's being created which spans across
billions of light years it's going to
have a minute effect on your genes and
your DNA while you're in the gestation
period so you become you come out of
that and you you begin to grow up but
those slight energetic modifications
become part of your personality Matrix
and so I do believe that astrology has a
lot of real uh real information to it
it's just that some people are you know
charlatans and some aren it's hard to
find a real good one but if you find a
good one I believe that you can find
some good information in that and in
terms of what you just said about there
still being um remnants of the anunaki
in like you know behind the cloak of
government and Etc David Ike is
definitely on board with that and it was
really interesting to he the way he put
them across of um you know they're very
aware of a lot of this information and
they they're shrouded in secrecy but
they are still very powerful um do you
worry that you're kind of saying a lot
right now and maybe shining a light on
you especially with you know the control
government and religion have over the
world still um are you worried about you
know how far you're pushing things not
really I think that I don't have enough
power as of yet maybe if I become a
little bit more powerful um I don't
think I have enough influence yet to
make an impact on a scale that would get
their complete attention I'm moving in
that direction but as for right now my
biggest threats are coming from the
community that watches my videos people
who believe in Flat Earth and I don't
believe in Flat Earth they want they
they sent me death threats I've had
three death threats from people that
believe the Earth is flat because I'm
talking about pyramids and and in space
um you know I've had uh people that are
going against uh that believe in
religion and I'm going against religion
and going towards spirituality and so
those zealots and religious zealots you
know I've gotten death threats from them
they want to kill me in the name of God
obviously so my biggest threats are you
know are coming from the people not from
any government agency which is probably
what they like let you know let you know
they probably want me to be consumed by
these uh these people that are on the
border of Psychopathic narcissistic
mindsets or schizophrenia or whatever
else or or a lot of these people are
really just um obsessed Fanatics they're
susceptible to fanaticism so you know
let the fanaticism sorted out sorted out
so you I just have a I try to go as many
places as I can with my weapon on me uh
I carry a concealed weapon if I if I if
I'm out somewhere else I usually have an
armed guard you know it's that's what
just that's the life that's the life you
live you know but my biggest threat is
not coming from the government it's
coming from it's coming from the people
yeah and in terms of like the Illuminati
and all these you know conspiracy
theories we hear about the government
have you done much research into them
and what's your sort of take because you
mentioned the old saying I earlier just
as a part of conversation but we see
that on the top of a pyramid on the
dollar bill like yeah do you have any
knowledge about that for example and and
just general research in that area it
was a primary factor in the documentary
I created which is an award-winning
documentary about the Black Knight sat
and so the allseeing eye is mentioned in
this documentary because en liil who
when you look him up and Google uh you
know what planets is UNL own does unil
own anything in space you find out that
the ancient Samaran tablets attribute
the ownership of the boetius
constellation to and little this guy
owns a
constellation now what's interesting
with that is the fact that on this in
these texts he talks about the fact that
he has this tablet this Crystal tablet
that can see anything on any part of the
world at any given time that means he's
got something connected to a satellite
that's orbiting the planet in a polar
orbit so he can see what's going on on
the planet and so I connect that to the
Black Knight satellite which is this
object that's still orbiting our planet
today that's on nasa.gov is it's listed
as space junk it weighs approximately an
estimated 15 Tons by them not by me and
nobody will touch this thing because
they don't know what it's doing but over
the years people have picked up a signal
from this including Nicola Tesla who
also picked a signal from this thing but
the signal has been deciphered by not
only ham radio operators but also an
astronomer who wrote an article about it
in Time magazine in 1960 and more
recently an NSA Declassified document
which talks about this signal then it
points to botis Constellation the ham
radio operators in the 1950s it points
to botis Constellation the astronomer in
1960 BS his constellation what's
interesting that you got four different
sources coming up with the same exact
location that this thing is sending or
receiving some type of information from
a constellation owned by a Sumerian god
who says he has an allseeing eye I think
that that Black Knight satellite or that
object that's up there is super ancient
it dates back to where borus was in the
sky about 13,000 years ago so it could
be at least 13,000 years old based on
Star alignments and it could be
transmitting in real time updates on
what's going on on this planet with this
abandoned seed Colony we call Earth yeah
I've seen footage of this thing or at
least what what looks like satellite
images of it and it is massive and yeah
it does begger belief what the hell was
going on there you've also mentioned the
importance of Iraq um and I thought that
was quite interesting because there has
always I mean the way America you know
has wanted to claim control of it you
know in the past Freedom Fighters so to
speak um and and and the importance of
what that part of the world has can you
elaborate on that for me m well first
and foremost be careful when America
wants to bring democracy to your country
because that means you're going to be
pumble to death and you're going to be
left with dust yeah uh you know a whole
bunch of blown up hospitals schools
school buses and a lot of dead civilians
that had nothing to do with anything
that's unfortunate but Iraq what's
interesting is after these 911 attacks
we got to go there we got to go get
revenge we got to go get these wmds well
how come they go look for wmds at Saddam
Hussein's Museum
the first place they went was to the
museum and blew the doors open to the
deepest areas of that museum there were
steel doors there had some artifacts
that suddam Hussein was claiming proved
that Civilization had started in Iraq
ancient Iraq which is suaria most
Mesopotamia and that they proved also
that there was Advanced beings with
advanced technology in the ancient past
the head of the board of Transportation
of Iraq had come forward about now four
or five years ago made made a big
statement that the original first
airports and technology that existed was
here in Iraq and uh he took a lot of
criticism for that but this is an
official saying he's not only does he
know it but I have he says I have proof
so what does America do they go there
boom blow the doors off they go and they
scour the basement of that Museum and
take artifacts and I have a friend that
was actually on that team who went there
and sent me photos they took artifacts
what are you doing to get revenge
against America when you're stealing
artifacts from museums something in
there that they didn't want anybody to
know about or they wanted to figure out
how they can work it themselves the
second thing was they went to the
zigurat of Earth next first two stops
we're going to go to a pyramid we're
going to blow it open go inside and they
took this object out of that pyramid
that looks like the disc from the
Stargate movie okay just like it matter
of fact I believe the Stargate movie now
was was was created on after this thing
they discovered I have photos on one of
my Facebook groups I think it's my Anon
history group from years ago that my
friend took standing there on the steps
of the zigar Roat with the whole entire
military they had just you know this
thing had just come out and they put it
on the back of a double wide Humvee and
put a tarp over it went off into the Sun
City never seen it again but again was
that the wmd maybe something that can
access or open a portal or a Stargate we
don't know but the real purpose for that
whole thing was three things to get that
information about Advanced civilizations
from the museum the second thing was to
go get this object that looks like a
Stargate and the third thing was to be
able to pumble the entire country and
steal all all of its resources form
halberton corporation which made 34
billion off of the cleanup which they
built like four or five houses and a
couple of gas stations for hundreds of
millions of dollars and kept the rest of
the money do you believe that we've been
to the Moon then or or the other the
planets as in this version of human do
you believe we won oh yeah absolutely
you see the moon was a recognizance
mission
they realized during a couple of low
lunar orbiting missions that there was
stuff up there that shouldn't be there
and they wanted to get their hands on it
and figure out what the hell it was The
Real Race To The Moon between Russia and
America was to get their hands on
Ancient technology this is what the
general population has no clue about
there are so many anomalies up there
there's so much stuff laying around on
the surface we got to go get this stuff
this can be the next technological
Revolution if we get it first and we can
turn it into a weapon everything is
about weaponizing the big race and the
push was to get this first and so when
they got there they began to bag up some
of this stuff and bring it back but now
we can't show you what's really there
because now you're going to be asking
questions well what's that doing there
what are these things looking like wires
why does it look like a torn down
structure see China sent the moon rover
and they made a mistake they show they
sent back live footage the Rover got
stuck in debris that looks like a
junkyard from Earth and they can't get
it out it's still stuck there till this
very day the images were too late they
were transmitted already no way they
erase the images no way to photoc crop
them or Rock crop them or delete the
stuff that's in there because it was
transmitted in real time so we know for
a fact that it's there also the
Clementine Mission from the military
they sent the L lunar orbiting satellite
with Advanced Camera technology which
transmitted back gigs of data and this
data is mind-blowing when it got to what
we call the dark side which is really
The Far Side of the Moon it crashed and
and didn't never came back I knew it
wasn't coming back when I saw the name
Clementine because that's an old western
song Oh My Darling Clementine you were
lost and gone forever they knew it was
never going to come back they want to
intentionally crash a sing into a
structure to maybe get more data out of
it but the images that anyone can
download are mindboggling images which
look like structures vehicles and what
looks like remnants of Technology
scattered all over the place so you know
we went to the moon in my personal
opinion but they lied about it they
created some fake images some fake video
clips keep it looking like a Barren uh
Sandy landscape when in true reality
it's all about Gathering up and taking
you know doing a uh I guess maybe some
CSI work to figure out who the hell was
up there where did they come from and
what kind of technology is this and how
can we incorporate it into our Arsenal
that's pretty much what it was yeah sort
of like a keep the public thinking
there's nothing to say up there it was
just a touchdown and then we'll come
back home
um and in terms of like the we're seeing
modern technology advancing at a at a
rapid rate in as opposed to the last
couple of thousand years like all of a
sudden things have sped up and I
wondered if you thought that um maybe
crash Landings of UFOs or anything alien
technology has anything to do with that
oh for sure first of all what they
grabbed on the Moon number one that take
their grab from the Moon and brought
back accelerated us the crash Landings
in 19 1947 super accelerated us what the
Nazis discovered in Antarctica with
these other race of beings that were
there this Aryan race see the Aryan race
isn't blond hair bluee people that's a
whole another fake thing that I was
unaware of the Nazis discovering
anything in Antarctica so can you um
yeah help us understand that oh yeah
they went down there they first of all
uh Hitler sent his people all over the
world even to Tibet looking for these
ancient Scrolls and scriptures and
papyruses to find out all anything he
could about ancient technology because
he believed that the ancient past were
more technologically advancing them they
finally were sent to they were pointed
in the direction of Antarctica and they
go there and they discover that there's
people there in this particular opening
about a 30 m 30 meter wide opening and
they go down there and they begin to
collaborate with these people these
people claimed according to accounts
that they we're going to give you some
power back we're going to teach you how
to make these weapons and take control
of the planet and we'll then when we
come back out to rule the planet we're
going to allow you guys to have power
that's what it was all about nothing
about blonde hair blueeyed and all this
other kind of stuff I think it was
something totally different and totally
Twisted by the general public it was all
about this race that he had discovered
there and giving them back their
kingship over this planet and then they
would he would have power underneath
them they helped him create these honobu
craft these flying craft that he had
some flying as early as the
1930s the UFO shaped craft that had gun
turrets on them part nuclear part
magnetic uh part U ferrofluid Vortex
engine powered uh anti-gravity craft and
so uh Admiral bird discovered this when
he went down there were some Navy
vessels and they were attacked and not
only were they attacked some people died
and he got sent back with his tail
between his legs and he said there's a
new enemy that can go from pole to pole
so this was an actual broadcast an
actual interview he was on so they were
down there they got this Advanced Tech
now why why I'm saying that had an
influence on us now is because during
when we won World War II we literally
took over
2,000 not 10 1520 2,000 Nazis out of
Germany and brought them to America
under Project Paperclip and we put them
in the CIA we put them in the space
program we put them in the military we
put them in intelligence areas we did
all this stuff to them and we and we we
made them a part of the United States we
actually became the fourth Reich in a
weird kind of way they made n
essentially from I've heard right that
NASA you know you know so we're talking
about man these guys brought all that
Tech that they had been discovering who
they themselves said they had help from
people above that was that was the exact
response they gave how they were getting
this technology so we're operating right
now militarily off of Technology based
on help from aliens that came to the
Germans and then we abducted those
Germans and brought them here and it
came to us that's how we became the most
powerful nation in the world
technologically for as far as War goes
so that's how it happened it came from
there you mentioned Anala and I think
there's a lot of theories out there of
why an talk gu is shut off do you
believe that's it's more to do with I
don't know ano around that area I can
tell you there's a lot of research going
on we have a new series on my TV network
on Forbidden Knowledge TV it's called
the secrets of Antarctica by Brad olssen
now Brad who's a very good friend of
mine and a very popular researcher and
bestselling author he went down there
and he was granted access to an area
where the research bases are actually
located and some of this footage is in
my TV show that I produced what's
interesting is you'll find that there's
bases there from all over the world
researching something that's in an
opening off in the distance what are
they researching and who are they
talking to just like who who was Hitler
talking to I think they're talking and
researching the same civilization and
now that the ice is melting they're
discovering technology there and I I
think that's what it's really all about
you also have another research base here
called the Rockefeller Foundation the
only one that's not a country the
Rockefeller Foundation is there as well
and you can see this just by going to
Google Earth and zooming in right there
you'll find all the bases and the names
of the bases are clearly labeled so it's
not a secret but it's a no war zone you
can't fight there you can't you know but
it is guarded with weapons but you can't
those Nations that are there they can't
fight each other there they're
collaborating but what's interesting is
Buzz Aldren went down there a few years
back and he made a tweet which became a
cryptic tweet he said these people are
evil we're facing the ultimate Evil or
something to that effect and then about
maybe uh 78 hours later he deleted it
but by then everybody had already
screenshotted it and everything else and
they said oh we had to fly him out of
here because he was getting sick but
something he saw something he heard he
didn't like it he didn't like it at all
so it's pretty interesting what's going
on down there but we talk a lot about a
lot of this in that TV series on my TV
network the secrets of Antarctica by
Brad
olssen so you mentioned Rockefeller uh
David I certainly has mentioned them
plenty um do you think that they have
knowledge of these um anari and they are
maybe part of it yeah oh yeah one of
them actually made a statement years ago
I forget which Rockefeller was but he
said uh um it was it wasn't a rock it
was his Partners the Rothchild actually
made the statement but they they they
collabed together I mean they both owned
the Central Bank yeah right but they
they said that you know we deserve we we
have the right to rule over mankind they
really believe that they're supposed to
rule over us and this is coming from
their genetic lineage that they feel
that they're directly connected to these
anunaki Gods who are connected to these
you know the gods that are on the
Samaran Kings list that rule for
hundreds of thousands of years you know
the Samaran Kings list is talking about
gods that rule for 14,400 28,000 years
and so forth and so on you got all this
list of all these people that ruled and
then after the great flood kingship was
handed down to man mankind that there be
one liaison that was half human half
anunaki that they would be the go
through person to the people and so
through that bloodline and lineage Here
Comes many others including the
Rothchilds and AR Rockefellers when you
look at the ancient text which where
alond raw was trying to escape this last
war he makes a very crazy statement he
says I'm leaving the kingship and the
finances to my raw C raw k m which is an
ancient word that trans now translates
now into the word Shield so 5,000 years
ago he left the kingship and the
finances and control over to the raw
Shield which now is the Rothchild so
this is ancient stuff man it's all
connected yeah and and and David
specifically when I interviewed him he
mentioned that there's the possibility
of they cons you know the the elite
level of of of these um anunaki can be
interdimensional do you subscribe to
that theory that's interesting now if
you consider that there are a lot of
different types of beings that exist in
the universe in my opinion and anyone
that's not from Earth is in anunaki
because like if me and you travel to you
and I travel to Mars right and they go
hey man where you guys from who are you
oh we're earthlings we're not going to
say I'm Billy Carson from Fort
Lauderdale Florida right so we're gonna
say we're Earthling so you know it's a
generalized term now because of that I
believe that there are multiple
Dimensions that exist in the universe I
even believe in the parallel universe
and also the Multiverse I also believe
that if I'm an advanced being that
understands I'm living in a
multi-dimensional reality and I have the
technology to access or find out the
atomic phase structure or the atomic
phase frequency of a specific Dimension
if I can phase shift my atom atoms to
that I can probably walk right in or
maybe even get a appear in or look in so
I believe that there could be
multi-dimensional beings that have the
ability to trans shift from Dimension to
Dimension uh or maybe a higher
dimensional being that has the
capability to walk into our Dimension uh
maybe even some of the Paranormal
Activity we've heard about for over so
many years going back even thousands of
years could be multi-dimensional beings
interacting with the third dimension
appearing like apparitions or Paranormal
Activity but it's really an advanced
race of people kind of have a peak in to
see what's going on here uh so I believe
that you know a lot of these
possibilities just exist and are are you
know our lack of understanding of who we
even are in the universe and how new we
are to this place puts us in a position
where the ego kind of takes over and and
presupposes that we're the end all Beall
when we're actually the New Kids on the
Block that really has hit me a lot since
starting to listen to your content I
think the the main thing that came to my
head is damn we are babies and we really
think we're grown-ups but we're really
not um and specifically there was one uh
account that you um talked about which
I'd never heard about before
surprisingly because I do love to learn
about this sort of stuff but uh there
was a mixed race couple that were
abducted and you said that they sort of
spoke about something that hadn't
happened yet but those was then later
proved to be true can you talk about
that please yeah Betty and Barney Betty
and Barney um they were I forget the
last name now Betty and Barney they were
actually abducted this is in I think the
1950s or
1960s one a real famous account a mixed
race couple uh they were taken on board
a craft they were just driving home and
this craft appeared front in front of
the car and it abducted them they lost
time and everything under hypnosis they
began to recount what actually happened
and um and Betty began to talk about how
they um you know started cutting open
her dress which the dress is actually
like you know uh it's in a museum it's
like really you know damaged you can see
where the damage happened they began to
cut up her dress uh they started to
probe her probe probe uh Barney as well
and what's interesting is they showed
her a star system she didn't know it was
a star system she saw dots she said
where are you from they showed her this
pattern she reproduced that pattern for
this um thisy this uh I guess this Psy
psycho therapist who P under under this
uh hypnosis and when that was given to
people to research it ended up in the
hands of an astronomer and the scientist
they realized it was a Zeta verticulus
constellation and that uh that's not the
only account of these beings coming from
Zeta reticules which is pretty
interesting but that these beings
obviously maybe had come from that that
uh constellation so we have an account
in modern times where people are
abducted and they recount where the what
these beings did to them and where they
said they came from and at the time from
what I understand that that
constellation hadn't even been sort of
discovered yet right it wasn't
discovered yet we didn't discover until
later so as they it sat around for a
little for for some time and then
somebody had an epiphany moment and
realized oh man this is linking to this
and they finally merg it together and
realize wow it's is it meticulous so for
me it adds a lot of credibility to the
story if we weren't created by aliens
but were um tweaked to become this by
aliens then in your opinion what is God
first of all I believe God is on the
outside of this these dimensions on the
outside of this universe I don't believe
that God is in the universe per se as a
physical form being I don't believe that
God is either a man nor a woman either I
don't believe that there's a gender on
this God I think that calling God a man
is probably the craziest thing I've ever
heard because we know that life comes
out of a womb but but the fact I think
it's an it's it's outside it's an entity
or maybe even possibly entities plural
on the outside of this universe outside
of all of these dimensions and that in
here in some way shape or form
this God has imbued the universe with
this Divine energy Divine energy that
streams and vibrates every single string
which creates string theory and creates
every single atom and everything that we
have this ill Usery of reality in this
third dimension and I truly believe that
this entire universe and maybe even the
Multiverse is a gigantic Matrix we're
talking about a holographic matrix of
light and we're living in a created
Universe based on real science we know
it's a creation the method of the
creation Now has also been proven that
we're living in a light matrix it's a
fractal holographic matrix this is
scientifically peer-reviewed now real
science and I don't believe that we're
living in base reality I believe that
there's many levels to reality as well
and this could be just one Universe of
Googles of universes that exist that are
created by different entities and I
believe that they're all in some way
shape perform experiments and what is
the ultimate experiment of this
particular Universe well because we know
it's a the fractal we have to go from
the large to the small and analyze what
we can see on the smaller scale that
represents the universe that would be
our brain our brain is encased in
darkness it doesn't know what's really
going on out here but it has sensory
perception smell touch hearing you know
taste and so forth senses it says to the
sensory friends hey go out there and
grab me some data so I can analyze it
and figure out what's going on so the
friends go out and do everything get
this data now the friends themselves
they don't know what they're collecting
they can't break the data down they
can't analyze it all they can do is
collect information and send it back to
the brain the brain takes that data and
then sorts it all out and projects a
hologram and we navigate through this
Matrix based on a holographic projection
from data collected by our Sentry
perception so you take that to the
bigger scale now you we were micro let's
go macro the universe as a whole is a
mind right the universe itself is a mind
and then we human beings and and and and
cats and dogs and and grass and trees
and everything else we're just a cent
perception for this mind and it's
telling us to go out and collect
information so we go out and we collect
data just by living our natural normal
everyday life we're collecting data and
because Consciousness is not created in
the brain it's downloaded and uploaded
from the mind we're streaming down
information but we're also sending back
data as well it's a two-way upload down
download and that we're collecting data
247 and streaming it back to the source
so that the Creator the universe itself
can understand what it's like to live in
the third dimension as Billy Carson as
you know true Jordy as whoever and so
it's a it's a it's a way of subjectively
living lives through you know trillions
and Googles of entities throughout the
entire universe to collect data now why
collect the data what is the purpose the
purpose is to understand what it's like
to live in multiple dimensions and also
I think the purpose is to find out how
long can a system take to correct itself
because we know that light always out
Powers Darkness over time there is a yin
and a Yang but there's a cycle when
light overpowers it then there a cycle
when darkness invades it again and the a
cycle when light overpowers it again I
believe that the True full experiment is
to see how long will it take for these
multiple species throughout the entire
univ to figure out how to bring Heaven
to Earth how to become the light and
sustain the light and evade or put off
the darkness I think that's the ultimate
experiment that was fantastically put un
unbelievable m i you know one take
wonder over here wow well done and um
and I've seen you um you you've also
detailed the the the the the idea that
we are uploading and downloading um and
that's even scientific as well yeah um
right it's been proven so you know it is
fascinating when you when you think of
how many times art is mimicking this
whether it be Matrix Star Wars Harry
Potter any of these sort of type of
movies it always does come down to the
light overpowering the darkness and um
it it's it's fascinating stuff and I've
got one more question but yeah I really
appreciate this m and my final question
is how would you like to be
remembered well I would like to be
remembered is a Pioneer um we're all
right now you me everyone else you know
working like this doing these podcasts
and these shows and making memes and
going out and speaking to public and
writing books and movies and
documentaries we're all a part of the
education process to help bring
Mankind's memory back right we're trying
to extrapolate as much information as we
can from the past present and the future
and put together understanding to help
raise consciouses on the planet and I
believe that um we're planting seeds for
trees that are going to grow that we're
never going to sit in the shade of these
trees but it's a real comforting fact to
know that at some point in the distant
future a lot of the work that I've put
out now is going to have an impact 15 20
30 a 100 Generations from now when there
is a golden age and people are
celebrating life and living in Warf free
and peace free and everyone's loving one
another you know uh and that u in some
way sh perform I might be slightly
remembered as one of the many pioneers
that help Usher man back towards the
Golden Age it it definitely feels like
when you speak and and you're talking
about uh people like Thor for example
you really feel like you're paying
tribute to him and you're really try you
care about it and you're you know
there's an emotional connection there to
this person of you know what I know
you've been forgotten about but I'm
actually trying to pay this forward and
and put people onto it and it really
does come across me so well done thank
you thank you I appreciate it so that
was Billy Carson uh forbidden knowledge
do check them out I'll put the links in
the description below if you want to go
there's way more to find out this is
literally the tip of the iceberg uh the
tip of the pyramid um so do check them
out um big thank you to Billy thanks for
coming on me appreciate it thank you it
was great we got I got to come back and
do a part two oh man if you're ever in
London that's when we we do part two for
sure oh yeah that'll be in uh 2024 I do
two big uh two big uh conferences in
London that I run one in London and then
one in Manchester so I'll stop in for
sure amazing thank you so much that was
Billy Carson the legend appreciate
[Music]
it